la plupart des des gens à qui ça arrive
ne vont pas en prison je trouve qu'il a
déjà eu un traitement de défaveur on
parle de traitement de faveur là c'est
un traitement de défaveur on lui a mis
un bracelet électronique on l'a on le
procure a demandé à deux reprises son
incarcération
heureusement finalement finalement les
médecins ont eu le dernier mot
il va être jugé mais il faut pas faire
le procès avant le procès je pense
honnêtement il s'est soigné visiblement
il va il va mieux il se porte bien
les familles des victimes qu'on risque
on est en contact avec les familles
victimes on va il va nous dire Gilles ce
qu'il en pense mais parce que là on va
voir les images il a été filmé par les
caméras de BFM TV en train de marcher
dans les rues de Bordeaux après avoir
quitté le domicile de sa maman c'est la
première fois qu'on le film libre dans
la rue depuis l'accident regardez
comme un homme normal pierre Palma
d'entouré de ses proches marche
librement dans cette rue de Bordeaux une
première depuis l'accident qu'il a
provoqué au mois de février dernier
l'acteur sort du domicile de sa mère
puis monte dans un véhicule en tant que
passager avec l'accord des médecins
chaque week-end il peut désormais sortir
de l'hôpital Pellegrin où il était admis
hier soir l'acteur ici en pull blanc a
bien regagné l'hôpital de Bordeaux en
attendant l'enquête policière se
poursuit un procès pourrait avoir lieu
un procès c'est pas que le procès
pourrait avoir lieu il va y avoir un
procès et pour l'instant il est mis en
examen
on verra au moment du procès mais vous
me parliez les victimes est-ce que vous
pensez que les victimes iront mieux si
il va en prison et s'il est condamné à
une très très lourde peine c'est une
vraie question j'en sais rien alors dans
ce cas là dans ce cas là on dit ça pour
tous les crimes prudence
Michel ce qui choque c'est le grand
sourire c'est le contrôle c'est le
contrôle
c'est le contrôle allégé c'est le fait
de pouvoir sortir le week-end allez en
famille je vous rappelle que le
conducteur est toujours hospitalisé
l'enfant il va à l'école et il va en
programme allégé pour aller à l'école
est-ce que c'est normal que Pierre
Palmade soit quasiment libre de ses
mouvements le week-end pour moi non non
c'est pas possible
c'est choquant moi je trouve ces images
choquantes alors moi il y a d'autres
journalistes qui l'ont filmé en train de
descendre d'une voiture pour
certainement entrer chez un proche et on
tenté de l'interroger pour savoir
comment il allait
sans trop avoir de réponse bien sûr
monsieur Palmas vous allez bien
comment vous vous sentez-vous
de faveur et à ce moment-là c'est
scandaleux soit il n'a pas très bon
faveur et à ce moment là Gilles pourquoi
il n'a pas le droit de le faire à ce
moment voici c'est la loi et après il y
a peu de justice qui a une caméra qui
ont une caméra braquée comme ça dès
qu'ils ont il a un traitement évidemment
Géraldine elle pose une question c'est
la question que tous les téléspectateurs
proposent et on va vouloir poser Michel
marin si c'était un autre gars inconnu
il serait où aujourd'hui il serait chez
lui très probablement c'est très rare
qu'on monte c'est très rare voilà donc
c'est un justiciable comme les autres il
y a pas de raison qu'on s'acharne plus
particulièrement plus malade donc il y a
pas il y a pas de quoi être indigné par
le fait que
la loi
de pas être d'accord avec la loi je suis
pas l'arbitre des élégances de de la
société moi personnellement à titre
personnel je ne suis pas choqué par le
fait qu'il soit en liberté un week-end
en l'accident a eu lieu le 10 février et
une fois de plus pour pour vous répondre
on a le droit de parler d'accord
je ne vois pas en quoi les familles des
victimes iront mieux si il est enfermé
et qui peut pas aller Michel il a dit
c'est pas l'arbitre des élégances de la
société oui mais justement c'est la
question c'est est-ce que la société se
portera mieux parce qu'on parle d'un
homme qui était quand même cocaïnoman il
y a encore trois mois qui a de ces
agissements donner lieu à la mort d'un
bébé est-ce que c'est raisonnable de
laisser cet homme là liberté alors je
sais qu'il a des interdictions
qu'il est sevré qu'est-ce qui nous
prouve qu'il va pas prendre le volant
est-ce qu'il y aura vraiment quelqu'un
pour le surveiller sur 24 déjà cette
discussion il y a quelques semaines mais
il a un contrôle judiciaire il a
interdiction de conduire interdiction
d'aller en Seine-et-Marne et
interdiction de quitter le territoire
français et Pierre palmal quand même
c'est un visage connu je l'ai déjà dit
je crois sur ce plateau s'il prend le
volant on va le reconnaître
immédiatement il va il va je lui donne
pas il peut pas faire 3 km mais si
prendre la drogue il y a beaucoup de
gens qui disent et physiquement il a il
a grossi il a pris beaucoup de poids
c'est ma mère notamment
et cetera ça je pense surtout que le
fait d'avoir une vie normale des du
sommeil je peux mettre ça mais une
alimentation
des des pays un traitement qui doit
passer assez lourd je pense qu'il avait
pas l'habitude de d'avoir ce
ses hygiène de vie et du coup ça il a
grossi
simplement quoi c'est le je pense
serpent qui se mord la queue non mais
moi ce que je trouve de choquant c'est
qu'en fait on nous a dit il est
gravement blessé dans l'accident on peut
pas l'interroger et tout ça un mois
après on a vu des premières images où il
sortait quasiment en sifflotant pour
prendre un taxi
toi et moi attendez je vais interpréter
excusez-moi
la première image qu'on a vu on était
quand même très étonné de le voir là je
suis désolé la justice nous a dit qu'ils
allaient le mettre sous contrôle
judiciaire il ne fera pas une journée de
prison oui mais parce que pour des
raisons de santé et un mois après on le
voit en weekend
prochain
exactement on était le dimanche 7 mai le
bébé aurait dû naître le 14 mai dimanche
prochain d'accord excusez-moi mais on a
le droit d'être choqué moi je le suis
profondément
et je me suis exactement parce que
Yannick aléno a fait un témoignage très
fort dans Le Parisien là ce week-end ça
fait un an que son fils est mort le
jeune le jeune homme récidive multi
récidiviste qui avait volé une voiture
qui conduisait sous alcool et sous
stupéfiants qui a foncé dans le scooter
et qui a tué son fils il est dehors
aussi sous contrôle judiciaire donc ça
n'est pas grave c'est la justice qui va
faire mais c'est la justice qui va mal
pendant quatre mois on en a aussi parlé
sur ce plateau
on a expliqué 10 fois qu'on ne peut pas
incarcéré plus longtemps sur les
affaires excusez-moi
toi tu peux faire une marche longue tu
peux manifester pendant 3 jours je fais
un cycine
elle va manifester pendant un mois et
puis oui Patrick et bientôt son contrôle
judiciaire risque d'être allégé y
compris en semaine Cyril c'est-à-dire
que là il y a le weekend et le process
normal ça va être qui pourra sortir
aussi la semaine et ça moi je suis comme
Daniel je trouve que c'est anormal bien
sûr que ce n'est pas illégal mais pour
moi la décence la décence stipulerait
qu'il se fasse discret qu'il n'avait pas
en famille qu'il reste se soigner
il est discret tu crois qu'il a fait ça
il répond pas bien sûr de l'hôpital
voilà je veux dire
il va pas faire des soirées